56 seconds of logos Comcast reading
unemployment is extremely low there's no
crime and there are less poor people all
because everyone is allowed to murder
people for a night there may be some
twisted weirdos that find this enjoyable
but I don't see how people being able to
freely murder each other for a night
would fix the economy and I bet I won't
get an explanation for does this movie
expect me to believe that the only crime
anyone wants to commit his murder I
guarantee there's some white-collar
crime that happens during the other 364
days a year if you're not purging we
advise you to get off the streets as
quickly as possible a purge advisory has
barely changed from a severe weather
warning because murder is basically like
a hailstorm also this isn't set in some
dystopian future according to the text
from earlier this is only seven years
into the future I feel like there should
be a few decades between not being able
to pass reasonable gun control
legislation and yet let's just let
people kill each other for a night girls
up to anything fun tonight
my kidnap Eva this year well we're about
two minutes into the film and I think
Eva should get a pass to murder Carlos I
can see how the birds got on so quickly
this is a future where people kill each
other for a night
and the iPhone 9s is shaped like a
fucking egg on the pay phone and the
government wanted the purge the new
fathers came in too often work boat into
one convenient radio that gives the
audience some background on the purge is
convenient our regime was voted into
office nine years ago and the first
order of business was to deal with the
epidemic of crime that was plaguing this
nation but the people out there watching
this billboard that don't already know
this or is this just the movies lazy way
of giving me this backstory and the
first order of business was to deal with
the epidemic of crime that was plaguing
this nation so after disbanding our
previous form of government the first
order of business was instituting a
murder Christmas because it was the
first idea in mr. Talbots
thirteen-year-old son it thought of I
guess basal protection of that this
guy's target market is the irresponsible
procrastinator you also I feel like this
is what her commute home is like every
day purge night or not we worship at the
altar of Smith & Wesson why would the
new authoritarian government allow that
stay on the Internet
I'll take care of my room I love you
both very much
that was weird as any fictional
character ever fully grasped when
someone is telling them goodbye what the
hell are they doing at the grocery store
an hour and a half before the purge
starts also why is the grocery store
still open all the people at the diner
we're getting antsy about going home an
hourish earlier yet these people are
just getting some food like it's any
given Tuesday
this goes on for some time was that all
about Lia's forgot the purge was
happening maybe that's why they were at
the grocery store if you planning to
kill someone it's probably not the best
idea to pin all your expositional
documents and photos to a wall that can
be seen from the hallway also did he pin
these items to the mall blindfolded or
was he under the assumption that he
would eventually have a lot more
information and he wanted to get himself
through can't go out there why is it the
pictures that tipped her off that he was
going out and not the bulletproof vest
does he wear the bulletproof vest often
I feel like it wouldn't need to do with
the crime rate being what it is hey is
this the second wall of pictures and
news clippings with redundant pictures
not only are the same two news articles
on the other wall but also the picture
of the house and the picture of him
smoking cigarette up close is the same
picture directly under that it's just
zoomed and cropped what does having two
almost identical walls of pictures
accomplish slow-mo shower to pad runtime
cliche the region
ocean of wealth upward through killing
has to stop
maybe this is why more people haven't
coalesce behind the guy his buzz phrase
skills are severely lacking his Papa
able to dress up then just casually able
to walk out of the house with no one
noticing
I mean yet no clue his daughter would be
taking a shower and his granddaughter
would be busy watching
anti-establishment porn but didn't this
guy just drive to the other guy's
neighborhood this morning before
everyone started to get purge ready and
just stake out his neighborhood until
6:00 I wouldn't need to be a reason for
him to spend time and money to suit up
his car and drive through a war zone
this guy must be a huge Punisher fan and
he didn't wanna pass up this opportunity
to emulate his hero just in case we
leave this gun on the table so any
intruder can easily access it it's a
good thing this chick showered so that
she could look attractive for tonight's
bird even though this line has been cut
the whole time the car was able to
operate normally until this moment every
Ford comes with a special wire that when
cut will allow the car to work normally
until no one is available to help you
it's a feature sheet they cut those
wires yeah but how did they know where
to find them if they were trailing him
the whole time we definitely would have
seen them before now also Liz's
character is born from the screenwriters
complete lack of faith in the audience's
ability to make any inferences by the
way why did these guys Park half a mile
down the road just to threaten this
couple did they really enjoy the sport
of it not like this couple looks
athletic or can handle themselves so
what's the fun in the chase plus we find
out later they're kidnapping people to
sell to rich burgers so the goes up with
this and for those releasing the beast a
successful cleanse is releasing the
Beast a technical term there is some SEC
school bro controlling her teleprompter
holy Sh
how far away does Warren live sergeant
was on his way to his house 45 minutes
ago and he still hasn't even made it
through a near-empty City I know Elliot
traffic is bad but damn government
officials of ranking 10 have been
granted immunity
Sergent turns off the radio right after
we have heard important info regarding
the purge that we haven't heard yet why
do we need to specify the murder part
seems the only thing anyone wants to do
was murder they should call out
something that no one seems to be doing
that would be more realistic like
looting they're stuck outside on purge
night but they decide to run into the
middle of one of the most well that main
streets of all of LA instead of fucking
hiding what stage weapon is a
flamethrower
feel like that's definitely a stage four
but this guy clearly figured out that it
doesn't matter what the blue Rollie
screen said there's no one out there to
stop it
this is clearly their first slash last
night of the purge any season perjure
should understand the value of not being
seen how does the point of rigging up a
door buzzer on your murder vehicle go
let's just get out of here or maybe try
a second dumpster wait a second does
this movie expect me to believe that
they were able to outrun the guys with
motorcycles an unmarked ice-cream truck
and machine guns on foot how are they
not totally murdered on that bridge this
is what happens when you only have one
night to go on a murderous rampage you
lose your edge Jerry Stephen Kelly
reading and narration also Papa's letter
is in all caps and his voiceover isn't
shouting at us I don't understand its
how the wealthy purge baby this flies
right in the face of the last movie when
it was a bunch of rich pricks running
around the city chasing a homeless dude
which led them to Ethan Hawke's house
these rich people need to attend the
Dexter school of setting up a kill room
also a wire crocodile Dundee's machetes
the weapon of choice for these people
they should have fancier weapons than
this right also if they knew this was
coming every year why don't they have
some special room in their home for a
purging instead of just doing it in the
living room they're gonna get blood
spatter all over the ceiling and that
nice crystal chandelier hey it's purge
night let's go look out the window
Sam what is with the people in this
movie in their opposition to hiding not
your little weak-ass protection was
gonna keep me out or what about the
barricade buster yeah but you totally
lucked out on this dude these women have
a gun if they had walked back to check
on their dad it probably would have
ended already there's an awful lot of
following around and not a lot of
bergeon going on right now this is what
you should have been done in the first
place this is what he was looking for
tonight Big Daddy we have to for your
personal purge expositional henchmen
just drive just god this guy was clearly
looking to exercise some vigilantism it
is highly unlikely that this side street
is on the way to the house of the guy
who wants to kick ninja henchmen decided
it would be better if they didn't
restrain these women at all I guess
hoping the flailing would wear them out
right behind us the filmmakers decided
it would drastically change the tone of
this movie if it had a narrator so they
just gave all the narrators dialogue to
Liz holy cow has nobody been killed
already
in an effort to conserve bullets
sergeant switches from that machine gun
to his handgun because he understands
that this is a be action movie and the
henchmen would let him kill him one at a
time the guy in the murder truck is
clearly still breathing just go ahead
and finish what you started dude if I
wanted to get out of the purge alive I'd
read that murder truck for weapons but I
guess leading them behind is an option
to Shane and Liz hop into an unlocked
car and neither of them look out to see
if the owner of said car is coming back
is this the only murder gang in all of
LA where are the birds on the school bus
from earlier why aren't they running
into more fucking people than just these
guys jeez how long does it take him to
get this gun up and run maybe this time
it's not a gun it's a Wayne's Lozinski
Street gray 15 seconds and several dozen
rounds later everyone and their mode of
transportation is still intact you what
were you doing outside
movie takes this moment to lazily pad
the runtime instead of having this guy
just tell them what he is doing Gary
what was in that truck using our passing
laws but the special kind of
armor-piercing bullets that just shoot
car engines and not people if it were
regular armor-piercing bullets they
would have gone through the car doors
and windows killing everyone we only do
i its purge night yet we are all
collectively deciding to yell in this
alleyway because it doesn't matter there
are only ten people in all of la purging
right now you can take a car and do what
you have to do we all have that friend
that lets people borrow your stuff IVA
is that friend make sure sergeant
expects IVA to know her friend's phone
number off the top of her head even
though no one remembers phone numbers
anymore we live in Los Niger's sergeant
is worried about snipers yet he's
casually standing there in plain view
instead of saying something like we
should probably get back in the car
there could be snipers on these
buildings you're all in my path
eventually no one will be in her path
because she's run out of bullets q that
wasn't close go to the business district
stay away from the gangs downtown in
other words go through the city the way
you normally would these characters
continue to run into the only fucking
gang they've seen so far we're gonna
have people in front of us we're gonna
have people behind us well that's some
super general it could apply to any
general situation all the Bergers wait
until Shane steps into the trap to start
shooting at them even though they were
doing plenty of standing around earlier
making them very easy targets even
without being trapped head up that pave
take the wrong if wrong movie is now too
lazy to find an actual screen to show an
expositional video so they just put this
video on a floating square and try and
convince me in some sort of video
billboard also this is what you get when
you let tyler durden edit your
propaganda films so quiet here
narrator liz is right this is worth
noting all crime is legal why aren't we
hearing anything during the fact that no
one wants to do any fun crimes like
stealing or vandalism shouldn't the
streets of La be filled with the sound
of gunfire
is this districts always quiet on
Persian ID the banks but that money's no
one's ever down here why though these
people don't have any anger they want to
let loose on these banks also maybe the
bank's just said they move the money the
misdirection worked like a charm
you're good with guns I'm guessing
you're either a cop or criminal because
those are the only two options for a
person who is good with guns isn't this
whole society now built on firearm
proficiency I'm gonna stop talking
because you're being an asshole okay
not because he told me this shot okay if
anyone is an asshole here it's Kali she
doesn't seem the least bit shaken up
that she almost died and her grandfather
sold himself to some rich people so they
could kill him with machetes hey
remember that I don't here hang
stockbroker David new satyr still on
pensions now he's gone
you would think David would live in some
wealthy gated suburb far away from
downtown that would have really amazing
security making it hard for David to be
hanging here but it would be wrong about
that because you also how they can he
read that I'm right in front of it and
I'm having trouble he's on the ground
and it's dark oh this isn't as much of a
jump-scare as it is a false gear traffic
cams are controlled by the government
how did they get into these and heave
characters don't assume and whoever
owned this truck just hacked into the
government system because dramatic irony
is for suckers why is it all red the
government knew you were gonna be in a
movie so they had to try and make it
interesting this is the only logical
reason I can come up with
that's Carmela's mark come on because
Carmelo steals a few of his vigilante
practices from Zora also this might be
one of the laziest symbols for a
revolution I've ever seen we're almost
an hour into this campaign and this is
the first time we've seen a group of
people actually doing something perche
was sergeant just banking on this guy
being stupid and unarmed that was a real
roll the dice and seems like it paid off
I hope that's not sexual tension I'm
smelling that would open up a can of
problems that I'm just not ready to deal
with you why'd you help us I saw you
putting up a hell of a fight
or they were the first people in mid
peril that he saw one of the two
there is definitely air in there all the
homeless people decide to leave their
decent hiding place to run directly in
front of the people who will kill them
more easily now Shane got shot in the
shoulder and he still has enough
strength in his arm to hold that gun
steady 30 seconds of just running a
traffic light camera wouldn't make that
sound but it had to so we would know the
nffa saw them on that camera
even though immediately after this we
see them responding to what they just
saw on the camera
why don't we need these giant ass trucks
for the government to kill people
wouldn't a larger van do the trick we
are on tight purge in this household
speak for yourself daddy no one in this
house takes away this woman's wine why
are we watching her take pills for a
weirdly long amount of time she's about
to be dead in like 30 seconds so
spending time on this is completely
worthless
oh what a shock the safe anti purge
apartment they went to just happens to
have a major family beef that's purge
worthy right at the moment the main
character showed up I mean why didn't
she do this a few hours ago
no they take in some strangers who could
witness this she's dead you're just your
sister Ruby continues to have characters
tell me what I have just seen he has to
be out of bullets now all right
Kali's reaction to sergeant almost
leaving is basically the same as her
reaction to finding out her grandfather
sold himself to some rich people to be
killed how they find it
everyone forgot that they are using
traffic cameras to watch everyone do you
think it's gonna come back stay put for
three and a half hours find a closet to
hide in these people definitely have
options besides running around outside
with sergeant they shot me shot half my
team I want him dead when they already
know this or did he wait to explain this
until they got here so we could also
hear what he said
what is this door made of it requires
this giant saw that produces these
unnecessary Sparks battering rams a
class-four weapon this guy is so
desperate to be a part of the action
inside he decided to go in there am i
leaving a spot on the perimeter that no
longer is secure giving sergeant a way
to escape annoyingly pointless GoPro
shots how did you find us we got lucky
damn right you got lucky you lost them
and found them three times so far I'm
not purging tonight we need to kill one
yet they still decided to wear scary
masks and wave machetes of people even
though that screams I'm gonna murder you
a lot louder then I'm gonna kidnap you
how does he not know what this is this
guy is so dumb I want to punch his
Friday Night Lights out this rich guy is
alone enough for none of his colleagues
to realize he's getting the kick out of
him this is why giant machete user never
as good as having a gun
this is Berger what does she think the
rules are if you're killing up other
rich people that want to kill you you
get to go home I love you I also this
asshole got the drop on five people when
he decided to take out this guy instead
of Sergeant that's the gun I just don't
care
freedom fighters ex machina there was no
way for surrogate of the gang to know
this new group is talking to them and
not the rich people these rich guy in
German are just standing in plain view
we need to be shot someone probably told
them we have ten minutes left and we
have to wrap it up
also these random shots of rich people
getting blown away feels so disconnected
they could have shot it in my closet
wait is that how why you're my shirt you
are tell
doing here well all crime is legal as
you know but the only crime anyone wants
to commit his murder so he is definitely
there to kill someone should house on
the corner the house of this drunk
driver is in the suburbs so what the was
this dude doing driving around downtown
LA the whole night before running into
these two and getting involved in their
lives two weeks ago I came here and I
disabled his back barricaded and you
think that between the time you did that
and the day of the purge he didn't think
to check and then repair his back
barricade sergeant's feature victim
didn't check and repair his back
barricade time is of the essence and
Sergeant is just toying around like he
didn't just bust his ass to get here
also the cares if there are five minutes
left if he murdered someone 30 minutes
after the purge is technically over
there would be no way to prove that it
didn't happen during the purge we found
your car sergeant your plates told us
who you were it was easy to see where
you were headed tonight yeah but see
this clock just before sergeant left
it's 7:00 a.m. now so why did it take
you 45 minutes to track him down
can't have heroes so then why waste your
time with this one dude who save four
people when there's a militia in the
city that's saving all the poor people
and killing the rich assholes guy who
killed sergeant Sun and we thought was
dead ex machina didn't you just get out
of a completely functional booking car
hahaha let's hope this guy isn't drunk
this time good luck getting to see a
doctor or a nurse or anybody a
hospital's gonna be compact
I'm on a volunteer as tribute
got some coffee Garcon means boy come
with me if you want to live uh
everything's under control
situation normal what happened ah it's
like weapons malfunction there is no car
Oh Thank You Bert rifle and basically
kill it every day working man and all I
mean I'll get a twisted I do some dirt
too but I ain't never put my gun on
nobody who wasn't in the game